hi everyone and welcome back to another
exam unboxing video today I'm going to
be talking about an exam which I would
consider to be extremely difficult if
you were going to rank exams on a tier
list this one would be right near the
top so this is the Nama competition
which is a math competition a math exam
for American undergrad students and as a
way to demonstrate its you know
difficulty you can look at what the
scores usually are so this exam even
though it has 12 questions in total each
worth 10 points
so that's a total of 120 points the
median score is usually between 0 & 1
and that's despite the fact that
students who sit this exam are usually
specializing in mathematics so that
means at least half of the students
often get zero marks on this exam so
that indicates how hard it is and I'll
show you the questions in a second at
first just a little bit more context
this exam was you could say founded in
1927 in memory of William Lowell Putnam
by his wife Elizabeth and I guess it's
gone on to challenge and maybe haunt
undergrad students ever since then they
give out cash prizes to the top students
ranging from 250 dollars to $2,500 and
if you're one of the top 5 students then
you can be named a Putnam fellow and you
might get a scholarship to a prestigious
university like Harvard or you might get
poached by a company looking for a very
talented students because the names of
the top performing students are
published as well as mailed out all the
participating universities sometimes
these top performing students go on to
achieve great things in math and science
of the previous Putnam fellows two of
them have gone on to win a Nobel Prize
in Physics including Richard Simon and
three of them have gone on to win a
Fields Medal in mathematics in 2018
the top three performing teams were from
Harvard MIT and UCLA so let's have a
little look at the questions they had to
solve last year so this is the entire
exam here now if you want your own copy
to follow along with there will be a
link in the description where you can
download this exam but let's first zoom
in a little and take a closer look now
you might first notice we've got
questions a 1 to a 6 in this first
column and then we've got B 1 to B 6
down here so when you're sitting this
exam you actually get two three-hour
sessions to work on it with a lunch
break in between so I guess you'll be
working on all the a questions and then
doing the B questions after lunch now
that makes it seem like you'll have a
lot of time to work on this exam but in
reality I think it's so difficult that
even if you can answer one or maybe half
a question for each session you'll
actually still be doing okay so each
question is worth 10 points and of
course you get 10 if you have a full and
complete solution with the correct proof
although you could get 9 points for a
proof that's nearly there and one point
for the beginnings of the correct
solution that are on the right track
of course you'd get 0 for any working
that's kind of on the wrong track and
also this exam is really about trying to
prove the statements you're making and
even if you say get the right answer if
the proof that you're trying to use to
show it is incorrect
then you're not going to be getting any
points for that fully solving just two
questions correctly should get you a
halfway decent mark and in the past a
score of around 40 was enough to get
into the top percentile from what I can
see online there have only been four
perfect scores in the history of the
competition these problems cover all
kinds of undergraduate mathematics they
cover things like group theory set
theory graph theory number theory you
know
theories of mathematics so the concept
should be no higher than undergrad but
the way that they're applied is very
clever and often the solutions to some
of the later problems they're kind of
things you would never think of trying
so very clever questions based on some
of the concepts that math majors I guess
would be learning about people that
would do well in this competition are
probably people with experience doing
math competitions maybe that is the
International math Olympiad which you
might participate in in high school it's
not necessarily just going to be the top
student in math class who would ace this
but rather someone who understands sort
of the tricks of competition math and
what it means to write a proof in a
short span of time that whoever is
marking the exam is able to understand
and follow you know and it seems quite
complete I think it is at best a
tangential skill set to I guess actual
mathematics research or being a great
mathematician I know I said that some
people who have done really well on this
exam have gone on to win the Fields
Medal but that doesn't mean that
everyone who does well on this exam will
be a great researcher and it certainly
doesn't mean that if you don't do well
at this you've got no future in math I
think it really does cater to people
with competition experience or that you
know really enjoy these sort of high
pressure environments of solving math
throughout an exam situation now I do
have a copy of some solutions here and
again in the description there'll be a
link to the source of these solutions
they're not the official solutions but
they go some way towards showing you
what an answer to a problem here it
would look like now of course if you're
studying for this exam yourself and
trying to work through the problems you
should take a bit of time to try and
solve things yourself before looking at
the solution but for the sake of this
video we'll have a little bit of a flick
through so just perusing the solutions
we can I guess see
some of the types of math that come into
the solutions how dense some of these
sort of proofs are that you're working
on our solutions use skills from
analysis from geometry even - we've got
matrices and linear algebra going on
here we've got some trig identities even
coming in yeah definitely we've got some
complex numbers I can see and some
really really heavy math notation and
yeah kind of an intense things going on
it's it's very intimidating I would say
this exam from what I've seen online
about the exam there are a number of
kind of tricks that come into a few of
the problems and understanding these
concepts could make the problems look a
little less intimidating for you so I've
got the pigeonhole principle the
cauchy-schwarz inequality for real
numbers and the am GM inequality so as a
math student who's done maybe some
analysis you might have heard of some of
these principles to just state the first
one in simple terms according to
Wikipedia the pigeonhole principle
states that if n items are put into M
containers within being bigger than M
then at least one container must contain
more than one item
it seems actually incredibly obvious
they're just you know saying if you've
got ten pigeons that you want to put
into nine holes one of those holes has
to have more than one pigeon in it many
things in method like this they seem
obvious but to have a principle and a
way to apply this to numbers in general
or to use as part of a proof can make
some of these problems apparently a
little easier for you so let's try and
comprehend the solution to one of these
problems I'm going to work through a one
but actually what I'm going to do
because it's a
lot neater is to step you through what
the solutions here say about a one so
let's have a read of it it's asking us
to find all ordered pairs a and B of
positive integers for which this is true
that 1 over a plus 1 over B is equal to
3 over 2018 I'm choosing this problem to
do because it should be the easiest they
should get progressively harder as we go
down this column so we've got our best
chance of trying to understand this one
here now the first step in the solutions
is actually taking the form of our
initial formula equation and rewriting
it in a factorized way now I have
checked this it is just taking a lot of
algebraic manipulation to get from this
form to this one it's slightly
non-intuitive to even think of doing it
this way along the way you needed to add
on a factor of 2018 squared to both
sides you had to multiply everything by
minus 3 but you'd eventually get to this
form here and that is actually pretty
great going on from there the solution
and tells us about the fact that each of
the factors so these groups of brackets
is congruent to 1 mod 3 now this
language means that if you do the number
mod 3 I guess you'll get a value of 1 so
it's kind of like if you were dividing
or by through you'd have a remainder of
1 so the value so the number 4 mod 3
well 3 goes into 4 once and there's one
left over so 4 would be congruent to 1
mod 3 so would 7 because 3 goes into it
twice to give you 6 and then there's one
left over so would 2018 squared that's
also the same also minus 2018 would be
congruent to 1 mod 3 that's because
three would go evenly into minus 2019
but in this case where one
more than that so we're going to have
one left over hope that kind of makes
sense but that's what that language
means so because these two factors have
this property I guess we also want that
same property in the factors on the
right hand side if we were to find the
factors of this 2018 squared so there
are six positive factors of 2018 squared
that are congruent to 1 mod 3 and they
are 1 2 squared so for what I mentioned
before 1009 four times 1009 and that is
and that makes sense because both of
those individually follow the property
and then we've got four times 1009
squared so these are the six factors
which I guess have the property that we
like so that would lead to the six
possible pairs for a and being the first
one being an a value of 673 and a B
value of one three five eight one one
four I hope you're not a calculator to
help you with that but I'm not sure and
then there's a little statement here as
for negative factors the ones that are
congruent to 1 mod 3 are minus two minus
two times one thousand and nine minus
two times one thousand and nine squared
however all of these lead to pairs where
A or B are less than zero and the
question stated that we wanted positive
integers for a and B so they are ruled
out so actually that is I guess our
solution there I don't know if it's
necessarily the best proof or just one
way of finding the pair's because even
though like we've spoken about this
property of congruence and the modulus
it's not totally clear to me that
because these factors follow that
property that you know these factors
would have to as well maybe it makes
sense but I don't really see much of a
proof of that but at least that's an
example of probably what is the smallest
solution in this answer book the next
question
after this is for a to like we might as
well read it so let s one is to all the
way up to s 2 to the N minus 1 be the
non-empty subsets of 1 2 all the way up
to N in some order and let M be 2 to the
N minus 1 times 2 to the n minus 1
matrix whose IJ entry is this so
calculate the determinant of this matrix
in now this question here has a bit more
of a long solution I don't know it's
statements about determinants in general
looking at all the indices you can even
see like one other matrices here and it
continues all the way on to this matrix
to doesn't stop until they're so yeah
I'm not even really gonna try to to walk
through every step of that because it'll
probably take us a long while I guess
technically if you follow the rule that
they should increase in difficulty as
you go along this one b6 should be the
most difficult question it actually
looks suspiciously similar to a-1 in the
sense that they love using 2018 as a
number I guess because it says the 2018
exam you know we're being asked let s be
the set of sequences of length 2018
whose terms are in the set 1 2 3 4 5 6
10 and some two three eight six zero
prove that the cardinality of this is at
most this here well I might be able to
flounder around for a while but probably
wouldn't get anywhere if we take a look
at the solution for six we can just then
does look through it there so hopefully
maybe something in there
could make sense to you we've got it
continuing on to the last page as well
cuz some remarks and we've even got an
example of course you can't use code in
the exam but some
these questions you know they're very
difficult math questions but if you were
able to write some scripts do some
coding you could actually probably solve
them a lot easier so I think in some
sense they turn into medium problems in
terms of computer science but very
difficult when you're just there trying
to prove them with math so I hope that
was kind of insightful for you
as usual with these exam videos I do I
don't want anyone to be too scared off
or depressed just by looking at some of
these random questions and solutions
because of course if you're not in a
class that's teaching these or you're
not actively preparing for and studying
for this exam then of course I don't
think you're going to do very well like
you need to do some very targeted study
at these questions otherwise a lot of
the terms and just the way they're done
will be foreign to you if you have
participated in this exam yourself
before and let us know in the comments
how you found it and what your opinion
of it is because that would be a nice
insider's perspective and a huge
congratulations if anyone who's watching
this happened to score more than zero
points because yeah it's certainly very
difficult thanks for watching and I'll
see you next time
[Music]